e
10 good morning being 10:00 we'll call
the finance committee meeting to order
for a hearing on Senate Bill 406
FNA and I'll call the first the only
person I have a uh pink sheet from is
Donovan
Fenton that's me good morning I'm a
little nervous I only have one pink
sheet though um good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee for the
record I am Senator Donovan Fenton I
represent district 10 and I'm here to
introduce Senate Bill 406 making an
appropriation to the Department of
Health and Human Services to increase
rates for shelter programs we have a
homeless issue here in New Hampshire
people experiencing homelessness in New
Hampshire was up more than 50% in the
last year there are many factors leading
to this issue ranging from housing
shortages lack of programs and income
levels this bill appropriates $2.5
million to the Department of Health and
Human Services to increase rates paid to
shelter
programs this bill requires programs
receiving funds to prioritize veterans
and the distribution of services to the
greatest extent practicable this bill
was amended by the Senate finance
committee to have the Department of
Health and Human Services require that
recipients of this funding submit
Financial projections covering the term
of contract as well as ongoing financial
statements demonstrating the financial
sustainability our shelters need this
bill to continue providing life-saving
services to New Hampshire citizens
experiencing homelessness there's been a
lot of bipartisan work done on this in
the Senate and I hope the committee will
support this important Bill thank you
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you for your testimony questions from
committee
members representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair it's not a question as much
as it is um
uh a notice um division 3 has a work
session on this bill at 2:30 and I
expect that we're going to go into depth
about um about this bill and what we're
looking for as a heads up I I I would
appreciate at 2:30 to um have sort of a
a a lay down or a perspective on where
we think the money is going to go
geographically within the state I know
we have big needs in Manchester I know
we have needs around the state and other
shelters I just would like to see where
those are uh representative thank you
for that I will get that to you uh this
afternoon you don't have it before thank
you Senator appreciate it represent
representative papichi Mueller for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you senator for presenting the bill I
had two very quick questions and if you
don't have the answers right now if
maybe they could be made available you
know uh first the uh 2.5 million that we
appropriate uh how much of a percentage
increase is that to the current amounts
that we are paying for shelter Services
absolutely so uh I'm assuming you all
have the handout y yeah so at the bottom
of it you can see that this will create
this will raise the rates from $20 per
bed to $27 per bed but in reality uh
true costs for shelter beds are $45 to
$75 per bed so we're barely even
scratching the surface with this money
thank you and um the last paragraph that
you were mentioning in your presentation
that uh the recip of this funding will
have to have projections and so on is
that addressing an existing problem
where you know the state is giving funds
to shelters and shelters get you know
shut down and keep the funding what was
the imper for that I mean I understand
it as a general precaution but I was
curious whether there were specific
incidents or cases that made the you
know Senate feel that that was uh
necessary because it seems to create a
burden on the shelters and obviously you
can justify that but yeah I mean thank
you for the question I don't think we
want to create a burden any more so on
shelters but we do want to see how the
money is being utilized and how it's
tracking and how we're helping these uh
shelters I think um you know good
governance uh we see what we're getting
on return to our investment thank
you representative Murray for a question
thank you Mr chair uh following up on
that I was asking about your the the ex
uh projections for the expectations um
for the the facilities is there a sense
of that around sustainability or are you
looking to see what um growth or
diminishment of people who are using
these Services um I guess just a little
bit more information about what you what
would you would see in those in that
request thank you for the question
you're not going to see any growth
because this money does not create new
beds um we have an issue where we had a
lot of federal money uh for these
shelter programs and that money has gone
now and these shelters have been running
at that capacity and they're all full I
don't think there's a single open bed
right now and all the shelters are full
and they've been running with all that
money that we've had from the federal
government but that's gone now and we
need to keep them sustained this is a
this is a Band-Aid for a bullet wound uh
this is not a long-term fix by any means
and the original bill um was much more
comprehensive but after working you know
with my Senate colleagues in a
bipartisan manner we kind of boiled it
down to this and the plan is uh you know
we're going to come back to the table
next year with a much more comprehensive
bill but uh this is a this is a plug in
this leaky ship and and they desperately
need this
money follow up thank you oh and nice to
see you here um I was also asking will
there be a growth in the population uh
growth in the population of the homeless
the people who will be needing these
Services I I think we are experiencing
growth in homelessness across the state
no matter if this money comes or if it
doesn't um you know we need to address
the homeless issue we're having in New
Hampshire uh this bill doesn't
necessarily do that this bill helps the
existing shelters that we already have
and most of these shelter beds like I
said are completely full or you know
they might have one bed open um but the
shelters desperately need this money and
members I now have eight more cards
we'll hear from more people
representative Stringham for a question
so it's at uh e extra $7 a day that's uh
just running the math that's roughly a
th000 beds is that the state capacity
right now and the follow-up question to
that would be um uh is your concern if
we don't do this that the number of beds
we'd have available might go down
because you're you've already expressed
that it this is not going to increase
the number of beds and all the money
that we're appropriating is for existing
capacity to help Shore that up thank you
I can't give you the state capacity I
think somewhere behind me most certainly
can but I will say
no this money is not creating bets I
want to be very clear with that um but
if we don't give this money you may see
shelters dial back their services which
will lose bets um you know these
shelters are are desperate for funds um
and the last thing we want to do is lose
capacity further
questions representative cambrell thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking the
question uh it says here in the bill
that you shall not knowingly provide
services to any person not legally
present in the United States so what
proactive measures are taken in order to
determine if a person is legal or not
you know I would um thank you for the
question I would certainly ask the
shelters that question um what I
understand is and and I've actually
volunteered in shelters before I've done
a 7 PM shift to a 7 AM shift uh you know
these are people in your community these
are you know local members that you see
often every day um
and homelessness can can really affect
anyone um you know it's a economics um
down on their luck people so when it
comes to you know legal residents the
shelters um have a process in place to
verify who's coming into their shelter
and I and I would certainly follow up
that any further questions from
committee members seeing none thank you
Senator thank you folks and it was
zipped to my Committee hearing so I
apologize I'm not sticking around but
I'll give you that information rep
Edwards we'll next call on Susan
Hampshire good
morning sorry I'm new to this uh my name
is Susan Ford I'm the executive director
of my friend's place in Dover New
Hampshire I'm here as a representative
of myself um from the town of Farmington
as well as the shelter um my shelter is
um a $500,000 shelter right now and we
get $2,200,000 from the state so that
means we have to fundraise $300,000 to
service the population that we serve uh
we offer um extensive Case Management
Services enrichment classes sobriety
classes mental health classes um and we
can't do that with the funding that
we're getting right now I am literally
Bare Bones I have one person on duty
from 3:00 in the afternoon until 7:00
the next morning and we're serving
people with severe mental health
injuries um
illnesses um people with criminal record
backgrounds that are are present on our
door and we're mandated by state
contract to serve them um until they do
something at the shelter I had the
police at my shelter this weekend uh
because somebody at the shelter
threatened to spray them with pepper
spray and they had pepper spray on them
we don't have the staff to search people
and their baggage we don't have the
staff um or the capabilities to make
sure that everybody passes a background
check um to answer your question about
IDs we do um take copies of any IDs that
they have on intake and that is our
first and foremost job if they don't
have identification is to help them get
identification um our services are
around um uh
self-sufficiency so uh our case manager
Works diligently on a case plan to get
them identification to rule barriers to
employment to offer substance abuse
Services if necessary we refer out to
other agencies for those Ser types of
services that they might need to get
self-sufficiency any questions from
committee
members excuse me representative
tki thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here today while the bill is
pretty bare bones in terms of it's just
an additional 2.5 million and you would
not be able to determine how much your
organization would be able to benefit
from increased funding let's just say
what would be your priority if you were
to receive an additional $25,000 or
whatever the amount what would be your
top priority increasing staff wages I'm
like I said I'm literally competing with
17 to $20 an hour from Burger King and
McDonald's and Dunkin Donuts are all
playing 17 to start in my area
follow up quickly follow up and what do
you pay now 17 if they're not alone and
20 if they are thank
you representative Hull for a question
thank you how many beds I have 28 beds
thank
you further questions from committee
members representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair um in your experience I I I
I I think uh the housing First Federal
policy hasn't been in place something
like 20 years and from my understanding
viewing it through the Liberty house uh
Spectrum um the housing first policy
creates a tremendous challenge for our
homeless shelters because we can't
eliminate the bad apples that continue
to abuse substances and therefore we
continually repute the population that's
in the homeless shelters exacerbating
and continuing the problem is is that
your experience could you speak to um
the the housing first policy and and
whether so that we know that as a state
whether we want to petition our federal
delegation to change that
policy I'm gonna be really Politically
Incorrect here I'm very sorry welcome to
the club
y um I understand that housing first in
theory works I've heard it work in other
states great I personally don't see how
it's working I'm working with landlords
that do credit checks I have a family
right now that makes
$8,000 a year and can't find an
apartment because his credit isn't well
enough because he's never had alone so
we have them in our transitional housing
not taking beds and shelters but this is
a family of four she's on Social
Security he works as a cook at the orous
and and makes somewhere
between 70 to9 $90,000 a year and cannot
find an apartment because he has a 600
credit
score how does housing first work when
you're working with landlords that are
not interested in housing first they're
just they've been burned so many times
that they're not interested in taking a
chance on a client they would this
landlords won't even talk to us and take
us as a as a a referral he's paid his
rent on time he's paid his uh savings he
pays 1554 in rent 750 a month in savings
every month for 9 months and I still
can't get him an apartment how is
housing first
working I want money to build an SRO so
I can put my singles that I'm serving
more singles now than families so that I
can put them in there into transitional
housing and work longterm with those
individuals so they're not taking up
shelter beds they're sober for about
three to six months and really working
on case management proving that they
want to to Really maintain sobriety and
put them in an apartment where they can
police themselves and we can have case
management but I can't do that right now
because there's nothing no money
available you representative cell for a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for being here and thank you for the
work that you do um qu question would
you happen to know what percentage of
the of the people that you have now
there uh might be veterans I have two
any further questions from committee
seeing none thank you ma'am thank you we
next call on Will
morning there is that on Crossroads okay
again my name is will arll I'm the
executive director of Crossroads house I
am here to support this bill um for the
reasons that have already been stated um
just uh to preface uh we are the second
largest homeless shelter in the state
we're a low barrier shelter we serve
Rockingham stford County um we also have
a a u the only warming shelter for
winter warming shelter um that serves
all of Rockingham County last uh year we
served 461 individuals so we serve men
women and families we can house up to 12
families and um uh the average day for
us is about 62 days um we are very ex
intensive on case management and we're
very successful because of that I mean
we uh you talk about uh housing first
and I will say that um one of the things
that uh makes us successful in terms of
working with landlords is that we
provide that case management landlords
are very difficult to work with if we
don't provide the the assurance that uh
we will work with them if any issues
come up over over
time um so you know we're very
appreciative of the fact that the that
the state increased funding for us to
$20 per bed from $8 per bed uh last year
uh this increase to
$27 is not going to solve the problem as
Senator Fenton said but it will um help
us through this period of growth so we
we are projecting that we will be over
500 individuals this year um and
continue to grow and the reason for that
is because we are seeing more homeless
um and and the homeless population is so
diverse now it's not what we all uh have
thought about in the past um the biggest
growth in homelessness as some of you
may be aware is in the elderly
population people who are on fixed
incomes um and can no longer afford to
stay in their places as well as families
and women so for example when we built
our facility back in 2008 2009 we built
it because we had more men at the time
um so we can house double the number of
men than we do women it has turned out
that uh today um we have many more women
that are being that are becoming
homeless and therefore there's a this is
an inequity that we have to to address
in our facility but that's one of the
issues that we have to address so we're
seeing more women more families and more
elderly the elderly of course um uh come
with underlying health issues with which
shelters are not prepared to to deal
with so we have to work very closely
with our local hospitals to address
those issues but uh the the the so we
would if we get this money then we would
use this money to um to uh support our
staff I mean our staff uh we start them
at 1750
uh case managers are $20 plus um but
that's again we're competing with with
the the the marketplace and in order for
us to attract and retain qualified
individuals to do this very stressful
work we have to be able to pay more and
we're we're really not there yet um so I
will stop there and take any questions
members seeing none thank you for your
testimony wow thank
you well next call on step Tower from
assistance good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee I am Steve
Tower from New Hampshire legal
assistants I am the managing attorney at
our office in Manchester I'm also the
director of our local welfare project um
which deals with legal issues involving
the local statute um which as you know
is a a program where municipalities
provide uh basic minimal support to
people who are poor and unable to
support themselves and a lot of that
involves referrals to shelters for
people who are homeless um I've been
working doing local welfare work for
nhla
for almost 10 years now and
the demands that towns are facing and
the demands that shelters are facing
have substantially
increased very noticeably have increased
over that time um so I again I recognize
that this bill is a Band-Aid to prevent
our our shelter system from getting
worse uh but I would urge the committee
to pass this bill and to in the future
consider more steps to try to address
the uh the homelessness crisis which is
the other half of the general housing
crisis that we're seeing in the state um
not to take up too much more of your
time but I did want to mention one fact
that even as a homeless
Advocate I recently learned and was
shocking to me uh I was talking to a
welfare director from one of the larger
municipalities who mentioned that um in
addition to the difficulties of of
finding shelter beds available
um in the past there had been the
availability of referring uh single
individuals to um um what are they
called
um I'm drawing a blank on the name it's
a the a facility that's a rooming house
a rooming house uh and that in the past
rooming houses were seen as fairly
undesirable and sort of a Housing
Opportunity of Last Resort for people
who couldn't get into a more traditional
apartment um but this local welfare
director has told me that in
conversations with people who run
roaming houses they have been told
that the the folks who are now applying
for that single room in a rooming house
are people who are making $3,000 a month
sometimes $5,000 a month and that is the
housing that they are able to find and
I'm sure they don't want to be there but
that's sort of the housing of Last
Resort and I I hear that and I look at
my clients who are homeless and they're
living
on8 or $900 a month of Social
Security and I I just don't know what to
do with them the housing options are not
out there the shelter options are not
out there it's it's
uh it's scary and I just think it's
going to continue to get worse in the
near future so thank you for considering
this bill and I I I hope that going
forward uh you can continue to address
this issue thank you questions from
Committee Member representative Edwards
oh so we've heard thank you for taking
my question and U I'm I'm I'm looking
I'm looking for your
uh local leadership perspective on the
answer to this and that is you've said
that we've got a Band-Aid situation this
isn't going to solve the problem you've
cited some specific issues where people
with resources are still struggling to
find housing do you do you where do you
think a permanent good
sustainable position is going to come
from what what might that look like what
throwing money at a ongoing problem
without addressing the underlying
problem is is is probably not good
policy do you have a a vision for us to
consider um and it's it's not exactly my
wheelhouse of of local of low-income
legal issues but uh as somebody who who
deals with the issue I think we just
need to build a lot more housing like 10
to 20 times more than what we're
currently building which is more than
what we've been building in the past um
we need to build housing at at at all
affordability levels um we need
low-income housing we need you know any
kind of housing you can build in
Manchester I would like to see 10 to 15
story apartment buildings going up
everywhere I think that's really the
only way we're going to fix this and uh
that's I'm sure maybe not an encouraging
thought but I it's
just
the the change that I have seen in the
demands of the homeless population and
the size of the homeless population
since say 2016 2017 to now
is very substantial and um it is a lot
of people who are not your sort of
stereotypical people who can't hold a
job people who who have drug issues I
have a lot of seniors who can't afford
the apartment that they've been living
in for the last 18 years or um families
who often again seniors who maybe their
their 50-year-old daughter or son moved
in with them and caused problems for
them and they faced an eviction and now
they can't find an apartment um because
the housing market is so tight that if
you have an eviction on your record no
landlord is going to take you because
they don't have to they can be very
selective in this market right now um if
you have bad credit you have credit less
than 650 or 700 a landlord doesn't have
to accept you because they've got a
stack of 50 other applicants for that
same apartment the first week they
listed it's we we just need more
housing thank you br questions from the
committee thank you for your testimony
thank
you next call on carara an I think it's
Rhoden Heiser home for all in home for
all
Coalition did I say your name right um
good morning uh Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is Cara andne rhen Heiser I'm the
director of the home forall Coalition
and here on behalf of housing action New
Hampshire um I am here today in support
of Senate Bill
406 um I would like to start by
recognizing that this uh is an off
budget year in the legislature and thank
this committee for considering the
emergency funding that as we've heard is
so desperately needed I'd also like to
thank the committee for your role in
moving a great deal of pandemic relief
funding towards housing stabilization at
housing action New Hampshire we
recognize the tremendous work that that
entails
um by legislators and practitioners uh
we did come out of the pandemic
unfortunately with an increase in the
number of people experiencing
homelessness and housing instability
however without the work you all put
into this uh we would be in a much worse
position the last budget passed by the
legislature included a $10 million
increase to shelter contracts uh but as
we've heard earlier uh from Senator
Fenton the per night cost of a shelter
bed is about $47 in the State uh prior
to this budget the state was reimbursing
at about $8 of that cost last year's
budget brought that number up to 20 but
as you can see there is still a
significant Gap and we've heard that um
from a few folks this morning
unfortunately this increase in the
reimbursement also came at a time where
we're seeing an increase in need a steep
demand for services and some of our most
critical shelters uh that will
serve uh so many people are at risk of
closing if we don't uh Grant this
special
appropriation um I serve as the Director
of Home forall Coalition and on the
governing Council of housing action New
Hampshire um and in my role with home
forall working with many shelter
providers I've observed for quite some
time that the demand for shelter is far
greater than um what shelters are able
to provide on the Sea Coast the shelters
are routinely at or over capacity um
which has continued to uh Prevail uh so
long as the housing prices stay where
they are and any units that are
available are so far Out Of Reach for
some of our most vulnerable uh residents
in New Hampshire when there's not
adequate uh shelter beds available um
folks are living in unsafe substandard
uh housing situations uh they might be
couch surfing putting other households
at risk of losing their housing um and
we see a continued increase in calls for
shelter and in a previous role I was on
the other end of the phone taking many
of those calls for shelter and this was
pre pandemic but there is no worse
feeling than taking a call from somebody
in the middle of the night who had their
one window of opportunity to flee abuse
with their children and have to tell
them I'm really sorry the best thing we
can do right now is safety plan um and
and sleep in the parking lot of a
hospital uh because there are no shelter
beds available for you or your children
um and and that's something that I think
we're going to continue to see and I
cannot imagine what those calls sound
like um if we're losing shelter beds um
and I I also want to just mention that
shelters are often the first uh line of
defense for picking up where many other
systems have failed whether it is
affordable housing uh Health Care uh
criminal justice or more um they really
play an important role um in our
communities and I continuously hear that
there is a need for better access to
Services particularly to prevent
homelessness but also for those exiting
um a period of homelessness I've seen in
my current role firsthand how
transformational shelter can be it's so
much more than just providing a bed um
we've seen that with those Supportive
Services and the right Staffing in those
case management roles somebody can um
really succeed and become thriving
members of our community and thus
prevent returns to homelessness but
without that support it's it can very
easily become a revolving door for those
who are lucky to get the opportunity to
get a bed um which there certainly is
not enough uh we saw the substantial
Investments uh made as part of a
pandemic that did help our communities
and keep families from experiencing
homelessness but also provided really
critical resources for those that
unfortunately were unhoused at the time
and in the midst of this housing crisis
our Shelter Systems are extremely
overwhelmed and without increased
support of any kind our providers can't
handle the demand um I also lastly would
like to uh close off um that we
recognize that the Department of Health
and Human Services did ask for $24
million for shelter contracts for the
2425 fiscal year and they received 10
million so again um we truly appreciate
your consideration uh for adding another
2.5 to help uh sustain Services until
the next budget cycle thank you thank
you
members who did you just
see
oh representative Edwards for a question
you appoint to somebody else yeah no no
that was me um thank you Mr chair
um you you're you're you're using some
numbers that we I don't think we've
heard here yet this morning where you
you said we were at $8 a day uh now
we're at $20 a day I I was talking to
the um the mayor of Manchester last
night and he thinks that if this bill
passes it'll be $24 a day uh or in that
neighborhood assuming that's a correct
number uh and your costs are $47 a day
and this will still only be $24 a day
are we still um on the brink of failure
of our our Homeless Shelter Systems and
and what what would that are you you
able to survive on $24 a day is part one
of the question and two um what what
does failure of the shelter system look
like sure um so I am not a shelter
provider so I'm not sure that I can
speak to that entirely but I can say
without um that support they're not
going to have the Staffing or they're
going to be able to provide minimal
support meaning they're only able to
triage what's right in front of them
which is the people in their shelter
it's not addressing their ability to
help them with the skills that they need
to to not return so so that's great I'll
I'll wait in case there's somebody who
may be able to answer the question more
completely than you're in a position to
committee
represent PHS thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question I'm just
wondering could you speak to a little
bit more about your population how many
people you're serving um so uh the home
for-all Coalition uh is not a shelter
provider but we work with shelter
providers throughout the Sea Coast um so
many of the folks here um that are in
this room we've worked with in some
capacity um our Coalition has um seen
amongst our shelter providers but also
uh not your typical service providers so
we hear from our food pantries that
while their job is to provide food to
those who are food insecure they're also
faced with helping those that come into
their pantries the ability to to find
housing and so we're seeing it across
multiple providers that there is an
increase um I can't speak to those
numbers per se um our Coalition uh did
work with many of these providers in
2020 to uh pilot a program called the
affordable housing incentive program and
I know since 2020 we've been able to
move just on the C Coast over 200
individuals from shelters um from unsafe
housing situation ation into permanent
housing with about a
92% success rate and that success is
directly uh a result of the shelter
providers we worked with who had the
staff and capacity to continue to follow
these individuals after they were in
shelter into permanent housing so that
successful muray for a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for being
here um this is a little maybe to the
side but um for my benefit maybe for a
few other others can you provide some
historical perspective in terms of where
we are now because it seems to me in my
memory churches used to help out with
shelter churches used to help out with
what they still do with food pantries
but they used to be a resource and
somehow that doesn't seem to be that
that they resource anymore do you have
any can you speak to that trans
transition to where we lost that help
and I'm no way suggesting we should go
back to that I'm just curious to
understand the progression a little bit
sure I think churches are helping in the
ways that they're able to um now I don't
know that all churches are uh well
positioned to provide shelter uh those
that are able to I imagine still are
doing so um but we also are seeing
churches step up in a way that they
haven't before in um giving their land
to the community to Steward for
affordable housing to play their role in
addressing the housing crisis um but
churches by themselves won't be able to
any further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you for your
testimony we next call on Ben Bradley
Association good morning Mr chairman for
the record my name is Ben Bradley I'm
the vice president of state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association we represent all 26 of new
New Hampshire's acute care hospitals and
all specialty hospitals um we strongly
support s SP 406 and the $2.5 million
appropriation that's provides to shelter
programs um you've heard from folks in
the shelter Community about their
concerns I want to provide a little
different perspective on why we support
this bill as well um beyond the direct
benefit to the homeless sp sp 406 would
help support our efforts to reduce
barriers to hospital discharge across
new hampsh
patients who across New Hampshire
patients who no longer need care in a
hospital are stuck in hospital beds
awaiting safe discharge for various
reasons one of the barriers identified
in a recent March 2024 foundation for
healthy Community summary report is
homelessness and housing insecurity in
order to move a patient out of the
hospital setting our members are
required to ensure the patient is
leaving for a safe environment this bill
would help support the uh access to
shelters where patients could be safely
discharged if they're homeless I
understand it doesn't increase the beds
but it would be deeply concerned giving
the existing scenario we face if they
were reduced in any capacity discharge
delays impact not only patients awaiting
that discharge but also those needing
impatient beds waiting in emergency
departments on any given day dozens of
patients in New Hampshire are waiting in
an emergency department to be admitted
for hospital care but cannot be admitted
because an inpatient bed is not
available getting homeless patients out
of the hospital and into an appropriate
setting frees up additional capacity for
patients truly in need of hospital care
s SP 406 would greatly benefit Granite
Staters in multiple ways and I urge the
committee to support the bill happy to
take your questions thank you questions
from committee members represent Edwards
uh thank you thank thank you Mr Bradley
for taking the question right I want to
understand the uh underlying logic
behind the statement that 406 will make
a difference in the discharge rates from
hospitals it's it's my understanding
we're going to move from $20 a day to
$24 a day that we're already at Max
Capacity in all of our shelters so I
don't see us this 406 moving the the
needle very much if at all really other
than to keep some of these uh shelters
from going out of business MH so how is
it you see from the hospital Association
perspective that this bill will actually
help your discharge issue well I think
what I'm the point I'm trying to make is
the latter point of your statement which
is sustaining shelter programs
beds further questions from committee
members represent thank you Mr chair I
don't know whether this is uh something
we want to get into in detail in a
hearing but I I'm not sure where the
obviously the the obligation to only
discharge patients if they have a safe
environment it seems to basically Force
hospitals to retain patients that no
longer have a medical need to be in the
hospital but you're unable to discharge
them what is the you know who created
that obligation and again let's keep it
short because uh sure I'll I'll I'm
happy to follow up with you but I'll
stick to um existing statute that puts
an obligation on the hospitals to uh
serve the community and ensure that when
they are discharged it's in a safe
environment federal or state statutes um
I would say both thank you sure
representative Stringham for a question
yeah thank you for taking my question
and thanks for your testimony um uh you
know the legisl made quite an investment
uh in increasing uh certain Medicaid
rates particularly nursing homes and at
home systems to provide hopefully more
access for people who are are uh ready
for discharge from hospitals but have
nowhere to go I realize it's early in
this bium but have you seen any movement
at all uh in increased uh access for
people uh who were stuck at the hospital
are we about the same place we were say
a year ago sure thanks representative um
uh like you said I think it's early um
that was the intent of uh our hope that
those increase rates would help support
those facilities that we could
appropriately discharge to um I'm not
prepared to speak to how effective that
point representa haen Phillips for a
question thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question Mr Bradley um I'm
wondering if you could just kind of give
us a
quantitative picture you know could you
let us know
how large this um undischarged um
population with no place to go that's
safe um you know how large that is for
the state certainly so the hospitals
have done a uh recent they did a report
in September we did a report in
September and we have a recent update
that's come out um from the total
comprehensive uh amount capacity that
are waiting in a hospital bed that could
be discharged uh for very ious reasons
on any given day it's over 100
patients um and for homelessness housing
and security I would say uh upwards of a
more further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you for your
thank you Mr
chairman next call upon catcher Fox from
good morning chairman Wier and members
of the committee I am Kya Fox I am the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health for the Department of Health and
Human
Services with a Statewide rental vacancy
rate of less than 1% and a median rent
of over $1,700 close to $1,800 more
people are experiencing homelessness and
there's been an increased Demand on the
homeless shelter system in New Hampshire
it's a issue you know the question comes
up how do we address it well it's a
multi-prong approach that's going to be
needed and the shelters two of which you
heard from this morning um non-profits
community action programs and
municipalities are all critical
stakeholders in the work to address
homelessness so s SP 406 has had a
couple of iterations and right now the
bill as amended and as it appears before
you would provide the funding um to
those homeless shelters and would
increase their uh rate from $20 a day to
$27 a day um and we again I think it's
been um mentioned we really appreciate
the legislature's support um in the last
budget process we're getting closer to
the uh cost which is about
$47 a day and that's that's from a
couple years ago so we know that those
uh costs have uh increase and this bill
will help um close that Gap and so
therefore I'm here to speak in support
of this
bill one of the things that's really
important to know is that these aren't
the only funds that the homeless
shelters uh have they do a ton of grant
writing and fundraising so their budgets
um we you know we have the allocations
to them and I have that information if
needed for this afternoon for the work
session um about how much each of the 13
agencies Statewide uh receive in funding
so they're cobbling funds together um um
on a regular
basis and
um let me see what else I may have
missed
um again we have 13 agencies that we
fund uh through the department and that
is Statewide coverage there are a total
of
950 shelter beds in the state that we
fund and um I can pick up some of the
other questions that were asked probably
um best left for the work session this
afternoon but I'd be happy to take any
questions questions from the director
representative shurki thank you thank
you Mr chairman very quickly um how many
with 950 beds in the state how many
would we need to accommodate where we're
at I I don't have the answer to that
question um I might be able to come back
with it this afternoon but um I I don't
know okay thank
you f the questions from committee can
can you attribute anything to this
increase um I think that the
representative from legal assistance um
had um a a good response I think that we
have seen the erosion of permanent
housing so a lot of the efforts rightly
so have been for the um the absolute
worst case scenario which someone is
homeless and so we have homeless
shelters we have transitional housing um
individuals who are stepping down from
another level of care who are going into
transitional housing we don't have
enough of the supportive permanent
housing um available to help individuals
thrive in their communities and be able
to maintain uh stature in the in the
community so I think it it comes down to
a affordable housing and that's all the
way you know up and down the spectrum of
independent um housing single family
homes Etc thank
you represent grassy for a question to
follow up on the Chairman's question
would you believe that a uh resident a
constituent of mine called me last week
with a 83-year-old woman who was in his
church who makes about $900 a week a
month in Social Security had rented 50 a
month the landlord went up to $1,800 a
month on her rent and she was basically
asked to leave her apartment and she's
now sleeping on the couch of this
gentleman's house because they cannot
her forther questions from committee
director next call
on Mara
you need to hit the right button and
thank you Fork
testimony um my name is Maria Devin I am
the president and CEO for families in
transition headquartered in Manchester
New Hampshire I am here with Erica
Diamond who is our director of Grant
compliance for the
organization um many of you probably
know about families in transition where
a
501c3 um we have an array of services
that go from um emergency homeless
Sheltering to actually permanent housing
um the work that we do uh includes the
largest adult shelter in the state of
New Hampshire at 138 beds for men and
women we also serve 11 families every
single night 46 beds at our family
shelter uh right now we have 84 adults
and 114 children which makes up 62
families from across the state on our
wait list for family
Sheltering almost every single night at
our adult shelter we turn away men and
women in the city of Manchester and mind
you the city of Manchester also has its
own shelter that serves about 40 people
every single night so right there we can
add up very quickly for adult men and
women um the need in Manchester is
pretty great but again we serve people
from across the
state based on our um budget for us to
run our Emergency Shelters every single
night is $45 per bed per day every
single shelter is a little bit different
if you have to rent a place we own our
building it's an old and horrible
building but it does serve the people
that we need to serve um but that $45
per bed per day does not include our
indirect costs so this past year I had
to put in a new HVAC system I had to put
in a new roof two years ago um so those
costs are not in that $45 per bed per
day that is the basic cost to run the
program to provide the services the
three meals a day etc for our
clients right now we have about a 1.5
million do gap between the services that
we provide and the funding from the
state so that $1.5 million gap comes
from our philanthropic efforts so you've
heard the shelters before me um and a
few others who have said that we're
depending on the New Hampshire community
members and businesses to help fund that
Gap and what happens if we can't fund
that Gap this year this is a decision
that families in transition is taking
very serious iously right now through
the years of covid we had quite a bit of
money to help support our services we
even grew our services over the time
that covid had happened when we took
over the adult shelter in 2018 it served
70 people we're now at
138 so we grew by almost twice the size
which of course increased the cost as
well but right now we're at a point
where if we cannot get more funding that
$1.5 million deficit is
unsustainable so we are looking at
decreasing our services and that could
take two different paths One path could
be that from Spring till October we
actually close down during the day this
is not something we do right now we're a
24hour operating shelter so during the
day our folks are not asked to leave
they can stay in the building they have
lunch they go to programming they meet
with their case manager and we also have
resource Fair
throughout the month where Community
Partners DMV welfare everyone comes into
our building to serve the
population if we're unable to do that
during the day we would be then sending
138 men and women into basically
downtown Manchester to find something to
do for the entire
day the other thing we could do um is
actually reduce our numbers our nightly
number um that would then reduce our
head count it would reduce the food
count um we would look at going from 138
men and women to um 70 back down to its
original size this is uh an issue that
has to do a little bit with the building
that we have um and it's because it's on
three different floors if we've closed
off some of the floors we then can have
Staffing in a much smaller place um we
run on a staffing model for us it's
extremely important to have the right
Staffing on for 1338 men and women so we
have three different floors we have to
staff each of those floors the reason
why it's important to have a appropriate
Staffing is number one it is a safety
issue number two we're actually looking
after people who um because we are also
a low barrier Shel shelter if they have
used during the day often times we are
providing Naran and calling 911 so we're
not having um overdose deaths at our
location last night for example um this
morning we actually had an OD um we were
able to provide Nar can but that's only
because our third shift staff stay awake
all night long and basically look at
everyone and make sure that they're
breathing every single night so the
funding is not a huge increase there's
still going to be a gap but for us it's
a way for us to shrink our current
deficit and that's really the most
important thing for us we do very well
um by raising about $2.7 million
philanthropically for our organization
which is actually quite a bit of money
um but this would help shrink the
deficit um and really help us put us in
a in a stable place for the time that
it's here we're going to be visiting
again next year I know it's going to be
tough another tough year but as people
said until there's more housing there's
no place for people to go we have people
who are in our shelter families and
adults who have um been issued a voucher
but there's no place for them to use
that voucher and after a year that
voucher becomes null and void so it is
an extremely difficult place that we're
in here in the state of New Hampshire we
also provide housing unfortunately we're
not in a place to build more housing
because it is too
expensive it would take a couple of
years to build the appropriate housing
but we have 20 other buildings that we
use for housing which are also not
running in a positive and so taking on
another permanent Supportive Housing
project is is something that's really
tricky for us but something we're
committed to we just have to figure out
how to do it happy to answer any
questions M Diamond do you have anything
to
add no no thank
you represent Edwards for a
question um thank you Mr chair and thank
you uh for all the work you do I I um
I'm curious if if if you know whether or
not Asylum Seekers that have that are
recently arrived in country if they're
eligible for your shelter services and
if you're seeing any increase in that
particular uh subset of the population
seeking
housing so we are seeing some folks who
um are illegal immigrants coming into
our shelter uh finding housing is
extremely difficult for somebody who um
is here and doesn't have the proper
identification in fact it's impossible
it is a challenge for us to figure out
we need to work with the Department of
Health and Human Services and other
community services in order to help
serve this group um we have had about 14
individuals at our adult shelter
throughout the course of the year who um
do not have any
identification it's not something that
we would say is anywhere close to what
is happening down in Massachusetts um
there's certainly a concern of that but
we're a low barrier shelter and as far
as I know our contract is that we serve
anyone who comes to us who is seeking um
support the bill says prioritize needs
of veterans do you do that yes we do in
fact um there's two prior groups um
prioritized groups that we work with
veterans is one due to the fact that
there's lots of other services out there
that can serve veterans and actually get
them housed very quickly so as soon as
we know that we have a veteran and at
our location um we hook them up with the
services if they're agreeable to it so
that they can be housed much more
quickly than um many others the other
group we prioritize in our adult shelter
is um uh young adults so um men and
women between the ages of 18 and
24 the adult shelter is not the
appropriate place for them so we work
really hard with Waypoint and other
groups who um service youth um it's
better for youth to be housed in a
different manner than at an adult
shelter so those two groups are
prioritized for us thank
you all right further from
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair
um you you you've mentioned this term of
art uh low barrier service something
like that um is is that a low barrier
standard uh requirement defined by the
federal government or through grants
that you've received what what what are
the circumstances under which the state
may change your designation and create a
little bit more of a
barrier I believe that's probably a
question for Kia um but it is in our
state contract uh we're a low barrier
shelter so um for example we accept sex
offenders we accept people who with a
criminal record um we accept uh folks
who other shelters may or may not be
able to accept um and that's what makes
it low barrier some many of our folks
are using substances they um you abuse
alcohol and or drugs um and as long as
they can be safe for themselves and for
the other folks who are with us um that
is okay uh we work with them on if they
want to go to treatment um but as long
as they can kind of hold themselves
together and it's a safe place for them
to be it's better for them to be in a
safe place every single night get a meal
um and talk with people about their
sobriety uh when they have a place to
sleep thank you any further questions
representative Stringham um just just uh
looking looking at the numbers uh uh
there's 46 beds in the family shelter
and another 138 so it's total of
184 capacity so um if your costs are 45
a day you're looking at roughly $3
million a year in operating costs that
doesn't include any Capital needs you
have like your boiler and roof for
building repair and so on correct so uh
obviously the community um really
admires what you're doing they've been
very generous with you and uh um I thank
you for for coming in I just wanted to
confirm those numbers thank you very
much anything further from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you last person I have a card for
and we're coming up on the on the time
that we allotted for this there's
another a group meeting in the other
here thank you for hearing me uh Mr
chairman and members of the house
finance committee um just for the record
my name is Rebecca Beaton I'm the
executive director for 100 nights in
Kean New Hampshire we do currently
provide overnight shelter Services um as
well as providing day services in our
Resource Center we serve up to 48
individuals including men women and
families which does include minors
additionally we provide um the day
Services three meals a day during the
week weekends we work with Partners in
the community to provide um food we have
a case manager on staff for both our
existing guests as well as potentially
um individuals who have the potential to
become homeless to help them prevent
that we do have a case manager on staff
that works with anybody who comes into
the shelter um and needs those Services
um we did just recently increase from 24
beds to 48 beds with the construction of
our new
facility um and the space potentially
has capacity for more um once we get
approval from the city um so this
definitely does assist that process um
but again we are trying to really fill
the like our beds are at full capacity
every night um if we have a vacancy it's
filled almost immediately um for numbers
in the last week we do keep this track
for the census um for the state we
actually had to turn away 21 individuals
including a family of three um and that
is typical for any week that you would
look at um and it does actually get
worse over the colder months um we do
continue to receive the funding from the
state grant and aid program um the
increase from $8 to $20 definitely
helped and this will be um definitely
beneficial to continue with more
sustainable funding it doesn't reflect
the full cost of the shelter bed as been
said before um let alone the additional
Services we provide um
the
sorry the average cost for 100 nights
based on our 2023 operating expenses was
4280 that is just for shelter Services
once we include all of the day services
that also provides services to people
$648 um we do rely upon mostly
philanthropic and so that is uh
unguaranteed money and so that does
cause concern for the services that we
can continue to provide um that gives us
about
$770,000 in philanthropic funding that
we are trying to get and that is a big
deficit that could be really hard to
close if those were to go away so the
more funding that can be guaranteed
is better for the shelter to be able to
stay
sustainable um that obviously does
impact whether or not we can provide the
day Services as U Maria had mentioned
that could potentially mean that we
close the shelter during the day and
stop providing those day Services adding
those people back into the population
walking around in our um downtown area
and that you know can cause its own
problems um we're committed to our work
we are we have some great supporters
but again um it's just it's not secure
funding and that can be a real big
concern um we did start out as just a um
hundred nights we were open for the
hundred coldest nights of the year that
is hence our name in 2017 we did become
yearround shelter because the need grew
um and then with the pandemic we have
been at full capacity ever since um the
pandemic started and federal funding
helped and but it's gone um so now we
are very much just relying on on all of
that um I do welcome any questions and I
do have a written testimony here that I
can provide as well appreciate for the
written testimony questions from the
committee members I have one more card
uh if there's no questions thank you for
your
testimony um now we have Michelle
Futures she has written test thank you
Mr chairman honorable committee members
um my name is Michelle Meritt and the
president at new Futures I'm going to
make this short and quick because you've
heard from um others who have really
covered this topic but I wanted to State
for the record new future support of
Senate Bill 406 um and particularly for
the overlap between individuals with
substance misuse um disorders mental
illness and who are experiencing
homelessness that this uh particular
piece of legislation fills a critical
Gap and helps to stabilize those that
are serving our most vulnerable Granite
Staters so with that I just wanted to
Again State new Futures support for this
particular piece of legislation I'm
happy to answer questions but again I
think many of them have already been
answered and I'm have written testimony
that I will submit to the
committee thank you further questions
from
committee all right thank you we have
one more person signed up who didn't
speak Pamela Kell um Hamp Coalition
against
domestic um
Domestic and Sexual
Violence we will now recess this to the
afternoon at 230 when there'll be a
another joint Hearing in here between
Division I guess it's division three
work session at 2:30 this afternoon on
this bill and on 311 so so Mr chair is
is that is that technically a recess for
this committee This was meant to be the
full finance committee today and this
afternoon is EXP Ely intended to be
division two and division three in a
joint work session so so are we
adjourning this hearing we're we're
adjourning the full committee and we're
recessing to division three uh thank you
sir for the bill people that want are
interested in the bill it's mainly
people that are interested in the bill
rather and division two is currently in
recess on 396 so if you can get over to